hello everyone thank you for joining my
name is Carol Robin I'm product manager
cloud storage and my name is Chris
Talbott I'm Korea's counterpart in the
product marketing organization today
we'll be talking about picking the right
storage class and before I begin I want
to give you a quick overview of this
presentation so we'll be talking
primarily about object storage will not
be talking about different databases and
we'll start at high level and go lower
and lower into details of how to
organize performance of your storage and
choosing the right storage class for
your needs
to start I want to show you how storage
is used across different industries in
different verticals and we can go into
all the details about each and every
every vertical but the reality is
storage use across the board for every
single vertical and if you're not using
storage probably you should look into
how you can start leveraging the data
leveraging that storage because getting
insights out of your storage can really
transform your business you can open a
new market in the opportunity or help
optimize your cost or ship no products
for your customers new consumers and to
get into a couple examples here so
storage is used for instance from
multimedia to store all the content
serving that content to end-users during
different transcodes of that content for
retail you'll be looking at different
ways to analyze logs what your customers
are buying creating different sites and
helping sell you more than looking at
healthcare for instance there is lots of
data for genomics genomes are very large
and you'll be storing the huge amounts
of data and who can go cloud storage I
want to tell you a little bit about
journeys that we see from our customers
and there are three typical steps that
we see from our customers how they
transition to cloud so first step is
called hybrid infrastructure so that's
when your control is still in pram and
you're just getting started with cloud
typically what we see it's different
bursting scenarios you're just bursting
your computer into the cloud or York
iving data to the cloud you're just
getting started and what we see with
cloud storage in those cases typically
it's different archival different backup
scenarios and customers will be
leveraging our core compute for storage
and networking infrastructure I'm going
level deeper next stage in the journey
is typically lifting ship you're just
lifting your workloads moving them to
the cloud without really changing them
much and some typical examples is moving
your databases like sequel databases
moving Hadoop
then you end up leveraging some some of
our existing products like Google Cloud
Storage for storing that Hadoop data or
storing different static content and
you'll be relying on Google cloud
platform for your scalability and
scaling to much bigger capacity and
making it much easier free over clothes
and then last ahe is running cloud
native that's when you build your apps
build your clothes directly in the cloud
and typically what we see there is
people who'll be leveraging our bigquery
our machine learning our spanner app
engine and of course large in cloud
storage for storing and serving
analyzing the trees content let's talk a
little bit about evolution of storage so
we did not arrive in object storage out
of the blue so it all started with
directly attached storage and directly
that storage is our typical laptops and
desktops that's where you have storage
right next to your computer and actually
of course and everything was fine it was
growing fine people are running
applications on a single box but then
people realize that it's not efficient
you cannot optimize storage and compute
at the same time and fully utilize your
CPUs and fully utilize your storage so
over time people realize that we should
separate storage from compute and that
allows you to optimize storage
separately from your computer and run at
full utilization both of those and
that's where Sam came from and with some
people had to manage different volumes
this is volume for this workload that
volume or that workload and they got
tired and they figure out they can move
to level higher and move to network
attached storage where they will break
on piles instead of on volumes and then
over time amount of data is kept and
growing now we have huge amounts of data
and the industries realized that they
can no longer rely on file API for
scalability so they shift to very simple
object storage API that allows you to
scale the huge amounts of data petabytes
even exabytes and trillions of objects
in the cloud and so today's presentation
will be focused on Google Cloud storage
that's our object storage in the cloud
and to introduce Google Cloud storage is
highly available durable simple and
secure object storage and go cloud
platform we call it GCS for short and we
see a lot of success across different
use cases with DCs and Google cloud
platform
GCS is built on the same infrastructure
as other inter
services at Google and we actually have
quite a few internal customers Google
using underlying infrastructure for
object storage and serving and I'm sure
you're using lots of external Google
services that depend on that that exact
infrastructure I can summarize use cases
with VCS in like three large categories
the first category is content storage
and delivery we see a lot of demand
there
so that's video serving image storage
image serving music serving and some
customers we've heard about is probably
Vimeo for serving videos Spotify for
serving music and lots of other
customers that store and serve content
out of DCs then moving to second
category that's typically a big data
analytics and general compute if you
have a lot of data petabytes hundreds of
petabytes exabytes you've got a store
that huge amount of data and for general
compute internal big data analytics use
cases you'll probably end up storing
that data in DCs and some examples from
different verticals that we see is
healthcare different genomics analytics
manufacturing financial aid Analytics
e-commerce etc etc and last but not
least is backup in archival use cases
and I'm showing quite a few of our
partners here and have long lists of
partners that can help you or move to
the cloud and backup or archive your
data to the cloud so with DCs with
Google Cloud Storage you have for use
cases that target different needs of
your workloads and different needs of
different verticals so I'll start left
to right so left is our multi regional
storage that's G redundant storage it's
optimized for business continuity
because it's your done and out of the
box and it's also great for content
serving and delivery because data is
distributed in our network and it's the
highest level of availability across all
of the storage classes so typical use
cases its serving videos serving images
and different websites and different
documents as well then second storage
closets regional again it's optimized
for hot storage hot data but it's
limited to a single region and what that
allows you to do is to have you compute
and storage in one single region that we
have lowest latency and high throughput
between you compute and your storage and
so that's typically where you see
examples of video transcoding different
genomics and different general computing
data analytics if you're running Hadoop
work
you'll be using regional storage along
with your VC cluster and then going to
the right we have colder storage the
near line is our in storage foreign
frequently accessed data rule of thumb
with which we typically give is if you
data's access less than once a month on
average or you read 100 percent of your
data per month or less the Nearline will
be the cheapest storage pass for you and
moving to even colder tier that's cold
line with cold line it's still online
storage but we call that if you data
access less than once a year
on average that becomes your cheapest
storage class and typical use cases we
see from customers they start with their
condom in multi regional or regional
storage that continence is very actively
used after a couple months people
realize that that condom is no longer
that frequently used and the typically
tear it down to near line so like think
of your document you create a document
you'll be sharing it with your
colleagues and after a couple of months
the document won't be that frequently
accessed so it's natural if you're down
the near line and then after a year
probably no one will ever look at the
document again so you can tear down all
the way to cold line but before you take
all advantage of full advantage of these
storage classes you need to get your
data in oh geez yes yeah and we sort of
skipped ahead so you know one of the
things that we talked about here at
Google or some of the challenges
associated with how do you get your data
to the cloud and try as we might we
can't move stuff faster than the speed
of light so depending on the kind of
data that you have the amount of data
that you have for a particular workload
and then whatever your network situation
may be you're facing a wide gamut of
ranges when it comes to the amount of
time that it'll take to move that data
to the cloud in addition to those sort
of challenges that come from the
infrastructure side and what your
situation may be you also have
particular needs for your role so
generally when we talk to customers we
kind of see folks falling into three
buckets right so IT infrastructure folks
analysts and marketers and then
application developers so the IT
infrastructure folks when we talk to
them they typically have a need to move
their data from either a current
on-premises data center or from one
cloud to another and when
being the characteristics of their data
is that it's large amounts of data
typically multiple petabytes and they
need to bulk upload that data to the
cloud without affecting their current
network situation and their current
operations now analysts and marketers
they're dealing with data that's
streaming they want real-time insights
into that data they want to learn about
their customers as quickly as possible
by getting data about their customers
into analytics tools so typically
they're streaming data and they need to
automate data transfer some from
particular applications into analytics
tools in the cloud and then finally
developers they need to build
applications so then you want to
transfer their data essentially in with
a natural fit into their development
workflow workflow so they want to use
the network to transfer their data into
the cloud so whatever your situation may
be whether you're on icy infrastructure
side or you're an analyst and marketer
or your developer we've got options at
Google for moving that data into the
cloud so if you have on-premises data
and a really good network you can use
our gsutil
our command line interface to move your
data using the network if you are in
another cloud storage provider for
example Amazon s3 you could use a cloud
storage transfer service to move your
data from one cloud to another and if
your on-premises data and maybe you have
a bad Network situation or you have tons
of data that you need to move we have
offline option called transfer appliance
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that in a second and then finally for
those analysts and marketers out there
who are using a lot of our other tools
we have a transfer service that can get
your marketing data directly into
bigquery which is our data warehousing
solution and get you analyzing that data
as quickly as possible now across all of
these sort of buckets of areas of
transfer services we also have partners
out there that can help you move your
data faster now I mentioned something
called transfer clients I wanted to
highlight this one particular solution
because it's a relatively recent
solution that Google has released and
this is our rackable high capacity
storage server for moving data without
using the network
so something that's really interesting
about the solution is we designed it in
particular for data centers so you can
order this appliance from Google we ship
it to you you stick it in your data
center you rack it it lives there for a
while you upload of your data and then
you ship it right back to us and your
data is available for all those great
services that girl mentioned in GCSE all
right so let's go one storage class at a
time and deep dive and talk about
different use cases and how to optimize
your storage needs
with those storage classes I'll start
with multi-regional storage
multi-regional storage is best for
content serving and delivery so our
multi storage is G redundant out of the
box we have simple pricing and simple
API to achieve the G redundancy and it's
really simple for business continuity it
provides highest level of availability
it optimally routes data within Google
Network currently it's available in
three multi-regional location it's US
Europe or Asia so for instance if you
select US will automatically handle
storing data and routing within our
network within the US if you select
Europe the same story applies will
automatically store data in AG redundant
way within Europe and make sure that we
have at least two replicas so you have
highest level of availability while the
data in common use cases for storage
class as I said before streaming video
streaming music or just having a great
level of business continuity because we
take care of all fail overs you don't
need to worry about manually if I lower
from primary to secondary we take care
of all of that and to show how really
simple it is I want to show you a couple
API so first one is creating a bucket so
that's gsutil make bucket multi-regional
location in US and then name of my
bucket and that's it as you see there is
no primary there is no secondary region
I'm just specifying that store my data
in the US and then we take care of all
the replication on Google side and then
similarly retrieving the data would get
standard HTTP GET this is my bucket name
Carol USM our standard domain name from
this yes and then name of my object
which is image JPEG and again there is
no primary there is no secondary
location
what's cool about it if something
happens to one of our regions will
automatically failover and route your
request
secondary location or tertiary location
wherever we have your data and that
means no downtime in case of regional
failure on your side because you don't
need to manually switch primary
secondary or worry about
implementing that code for switching
primary primary to secondary in a
similar way the storage class is
optimized for end-user latency so we'll
be serving data from the closest
available region or cost available
location from where the request came
from will also cache data in the regions
that are nearest to those end users are
accessing that data and if you mark your
data is public that means it's like
cacheable and like far edges of our
network will cache it in more than 100
points of presence from where the data
was accessed from and to talk a little
bit more about that caching there is
quite a few things that are embedded
with this multi-regional storage in this
yes in general so I want to spend a
minute and explain how does this
multi-regional Storage compares though
standard solutions in the market
typically what you see from other cloud
providers or standard applications how
you store your data your consumers would
go directly over public internet or
different providers to location or the
tree tree for the day they store it for
instance in this picture consumers from
a laptop is going directly to region B
with DCs our approach is very different
so you'll hit the closest point of
presence and Google Network and Google
Network is huge like Google works really
well and we leverage same network with
the ETS and she'll hit the closest point
of presence if your objects are marked
as public will check in the cache do we
have this data in the cache and then
we'll serve it directly out of the cache
without going all the way to storage
level and if we don't have the data in
the cache we'll figure out which region
is closest to this locations region A or
region D and will serve data directly
out of that region which you share one
is closest and that really helps
optimize end-user latency and some of
our customers for highly cashable data
they get insane performance again like
millisecond level performance of a
serving data out of those pops in terms
of pricing as I said before pricing is
very simple we charge is simple 2.6
cents per gigabyte month in this multi
region location and that's per logical
data we don't charge you for primary
replicas or secondary replicas we don't
charge you for replication of data
between those two regions everything is
included in terms of storage in this
price and so it's G redundant we take
care of this replication for each and
writes we have industry standard price
or how much we charge and it's really
like super low points point four cents
per 10,000 operations for EADS
and point five four thousand operations
right we provide highest level of
availability that's three and a half
nine surveil ability slave with its
product and the it operates live and
higher it's designed for even higher
availability these three half nights and
again industry standard eleven nines or
annual durability and we have the same
eleven nine across all of our products
for your ability before we tip dive into
hopped it how to optimize your
performance with different storage
classes I'm going to show you how we lay
out data in simple terms and that really
help will help you intuition or how to
use the storage classroom situations so
starting with multi-regional very
simplistic view each two replicas and we
have easter applicants in two different
regions so as you see in this chart you
may not have all of your data image
particular region so you will not have
all of your data in region a region B or
agency but for each object will have two
replicas that are G redundant and we
know the teardown that replication is
synchronous way and so for instance if
you are serving this content there is no
guarantee that all of it will be in each
particular region but we'll have your
applicants of that con then going to
regional storage situation the regional
is different so for instance if you
selected region B for your regional
storage all of your data will be in that
region B it will be your done on the
cross availability zones within region B
and all of it will be within that single
region so that means if you select your
compute cluster in that same region
you'll have highest level of performance
between your storage and compute because
all of your data is in that region you
don't need to go across regions on our
network and then with Nearline and cold
line if you select
multi-regional locations on your line
and cold line those two storage classes
are not G redundant which is different
from our multi-regional storage class
but with nearly none : it will be stored
in one of the regions that are part not
region with an airline unquote then you
also have an option to select the
regional location you can say store all
my data in region B and in that case it
will behave very similarly to regional
storage class where all of the data is
in one region let's look a little bit
about those best practices so as you
might understand you want to take full
advantage of our network and when you
think about our network you don't want
to proxy everything through a single
location you want your end consumers
directly accessing GCS and that will
allow you to scale to a TV ps1 on turbit
and speeds because you'll be taking full
advantage of Google Network instead of
trying to go through a single endpoint
or single pop and that's really the way
for our customers to scale the huge huge
volumes of traffic then a similar way if
you have lots of requests coming to
those objects please paralyze them
because that will also allow you to take
full advantage of our network with
having lots of parallel requests coming
at the same time and then favored larger
requests because larger objects will
move faster and our amazing network and
paralyze small operations just a
paralyzing everything don't have those
sequential operations like it doesn't
make sense to millions sequential
operation operations if you can paralyze
them all of them will complete faster if
they're going in parallel and some rules
of thumb for a single stream for right
we have roughly half a DBS or single
string of read we have roughly 1 Gbps
and if you paralyze it it scales almost
linearly with having multiple streams I
can same DCs in parallel yeah so
multi-regional storage it's the storage
class that a lot of our customers use
for serving their content to users
throughout the globe so we've been
talking a lot we've been talking very
fast and we want to switch it up a
little bit and show everyone a demo very
simple demo of the few steps that it
takes to upload your content into GCS
and then I'm gonna show one of the
unique differentiators are built in edge
cache that Kirill mentioned and we're
also going to switch up role so we've
had the product guy pitching the whole
time so and we're gonna have the market
are actually demo the product so I'm
gonna switch over to the console and
once I get there I'm going to reconnect
cuz we've been as I said talking for a
little while so for those of you who are
unfamiliar what you're looking at is the
Google cloud platform console this is
how all of our users and customers they
interact with all of the services that
Google cloud provides so you can see all
these services over here on the
left-hand navigation we're gonna store
some stuff so I need to use some storage
very obviously so I'm gonna go into the
storage browser and for the purposes of
this demo we're just going to create a
bucket and we're gonna upload an image
so escrow mentions the way that object
storage works is you organize your data
into these buckets
to which you put your data so I'm gonna
create a new bucket here and I'm just
gonna name it let's name it the cloud
on-air demo bucket will select
multi-regional so you're just talking
about multi-regional and we'll have that
data live in the US and will create that
bucket so now I have my bucket and I
need to find some data to put into it so
I'm going to upload some files and I
have a list of various images that I've
used for demos I hope they were good you
saw our Lego chickens so why not use the
image from the slide and we will upload
this Lego chicken and there you go
here is our Lego chicken image in our
multi-regional us bucket it's as simple
as that right a few steps to get your
data into GCS and once your data is
there you can serve it to content or you
can serve it to users throughout the
globe or expose it to any of other
services that are available from Google
cloud platform now
I mentioned I wanted to show one of the
unique differentiators that comes from
GCS and that global Milton edge caching
that we do so it's really hard for me to
simulate a user at this point in time
requesting data from like London for
instance from here so what I could do is
I could show you us requesting data from
a bucket that's perhaps multi-regional
bucket in the EU so I'll go back to my
storage browser and you can see I have
various buckets in various locations
throughout the globe
I will go to this Chris's EU bucket in
it I have our Lego chicken image and I'm
going to run a simple script essentially
what I'm gonna ask it is to tell me how
long it takes to request this image from
that bucket in the EU so let's run this
and you can see down here this 799
milliseconds so which is pretty good
right it's going a long way to request
this information from the other side
from the other side of the planet yes
but we can do better right so I
mentioned unique to Google we have that
global built in edge cache so I need to
enable that
caching so I'm going to share this Lego
chicken image publicly I'm just gonna
make sure that the cache control is
cleared out here and now that I've done
that I've essentially enabled that edge
caching and we're going to run our
script again getting a little bit better
526 milliseconds and there you go down
to 31 milliseconds so a massive massive
difference in how fast a user would be
able to get that content because Google
is essentially trying to push it as
close as possible to me requesting that
information from the EU so for you as
customers of GCS whether you're in Tokyo
or or you have users in Tokyo or London
or Mumbai we're basically going to try
to give those users requesting your
content the best experience possible for
call that serving yeah that's phenomenal
and it was one megabyte object or
something yeah big object yeah the Lego
chicken was a large chicken all right so
let's switch back though our storage
classes and we'll talk about regional
storage class now so regional storage is
the storage that's best for data
analytics and it's really best for eight
analytics because you can select your
region where to store your data and you
can run your computer and run different
cloud platform tools within the same
region it's redundant in the region it's
you're down on the cross multiple
availability zones to achieve that high
level of availability and it's
integrated with all their standard
Google cloud platform tools or products
like data floor ml bigquery cloud
genomics and obviously compute engine
but this is the really they brought the
storage class to use with all those
tools it's ideal pruning general compute
within a single region different data
analytics use cases with Hadoop with
Cloud Data frog dataflow also for
serving the content within one
constraint geographic location and you
can also use the storage class for
region shielding with the content
delivery networks if you want to have
predictability on latency where you
start latex stored and where you're
exiting our network with CDN shielding
for instance let me show you an example
of using the storage class with do so we
talked about that lifting shift the use
case for our customers and their during
the cloud and for customers that already
have Hadoop clusters and pram and they
want
looks and ship them to the cloud and run
that or Culloden McHale will have a
perfect product for that it's called
cloud data proc it's essentially manage
spark in Hadoop service on cloud storage
and what's cool about that progress has
cloud storage connector and that
connector is HDFS compliant so that
means to migrate your storage to DCs
with all you need to do is just change
your pointer to where your data is
stored
instead of having HDFS pointer just
having gdgs pointer and that's it you
don't need to do any other changes with
the storage you just change where your
data is stored and since you uploaded to
DCs change from the HDFS to GS and
you're done like everything else will
keep working and what's great about
using Google Cloud Storage versus using
coupon pram is that you can shut down
your cluster any data will still be
there in GCS you can spin up another
cluster next data so the data is
accessible when your cluster is turned
down and that allows you to save a lot
of money on that compute capacity you
can scale down scale up your computer
cluster independently from storage and
you can learn more about data proc and
that cloud storage connector on cloud
goal accomplished theta clock in terms
of pricing pricing structure is very
similar to multi-regional again it's
simple
in case of regionals it's 2 cents per
gigabyte month versus 2.6 cents per
gigabyte month and pricing is slightly
different around the world but this is
our typical price in US Europe and the
major locations in Asia read operations
write operations are the same as with
multi-regional storage our availability
of slaves is three nines in this product
design permanent even higher
availability again oldest under stop the
same durability the same instant access
the same API so as you saw it was very
simple to create multi regional bucket
of API is exactly the same to regional
storage is specified its regional
storage and not multi-regional in terms
of best practices for using regional and
optimizing that performance when you're
running those analytics were closed when
you're accessing storage from compute
engine
you should be co-locating your data and
compute yearly selecting the same region
for storing your data and where you're
on your compute because it decreases
your latency make sure you have the
highest throughput it also optimizes
your predictability because you have
predictable tail latency since your
data's co-located with your compute and
all the standard stuff Burleigh
your operations because you can still
take full advantage of single region uh
let's talk about cool data so cool data
we have two storage classes that's near
line at polled line I'll start with near
line Senor line is our storage class
that's best for in frequently accessed
data it has the same online latency the
same API X are the storage classes
common use cases is serving long-tailed
content so remember I said it has online
latency so you can still use the storage
class for serving your content but if
it's a dead fund and not that Act not
that actively used just put it an
airline and serve it directly out of
Nearline in terms of storage price we
charge significantly less which are
generally 1 cent per gigabyte month but
we charge one cent per gigabyte red and
those two numbers work out to the true
love thumb that if you data's access
lesson once a month on average near line
is really the cheapest storage class for
you a couple other differences versus
near line and regional so minimal
storage duration in near line is thirty
days we did not have the concept for our
hot storage class when your line we have
it simply because we charge so little
for that storage and this storage
process designed for like longer live
content versus regional where you can
have temporary store data and then
slightly lower availability SLA again a
web team eyes this product or that low
price low price and infrequent access so
our availability is late is tonight but
it's designed to run at three nine so
for ability and then moving to cold line
so-called line you'll see is very very
similar to near line so with cold line
we still have on line latency you can
still actually use the storage class
serving your content it's the same API
the same consistent API as any other one
second
so it's archive storage that has
millisecond latency
yeah its archive storage with online
latency as I say it's archive storage
that you can actually use because you
can archive data and whenever you need
it you can still access it use it
anytime you need you don't need to wait
for that retrieval from tape or any
other semi offline offline storage that
you're using and we have some customers
actually use cold line for serving
content customers that have just huge
amount of content that really long tail
content they put some parts of the
content and coal-mining they still serve
it out just because it's not access
frequently and in terms of pricing
it's lower than Nearline for storage
it's point seven cents per gigabyte
month and we charge more for data access
and those two numbers work out to the
trill of thousands if you date access
less than once a year on average then
polled line is the cheapest storage
class just to show you how consistent
that API in that performances so with
API it will look exactly the same or
showing the multi-regional storage so my
bucket is called cold line I've claimed
that name from my storage class again
same domain name and image that G pack
and stand there get interface for
getting the data in and out for
performance I'm showing gsutil birthday
acts so it's similar to the tool that
Chris was showing but with birthday I
get our curve diagnostic as part of
gsutil which is our storage utility and
here I was downloading one megabyte
objects out of cold line I was not as
far as London versus us in that example
but at that case when I was testing if I
was in London and data was in Belgium so
there was a little bit of extra Hall
there and you can see in this example
it's consistent performances between 147
milliseconds up to 200 millisecond
foreign lonely at 1 megabyte object out
of cold me that's crazy that's our
archive store if we had wanted to I
couldn't serve that Lego chicken image
Cove I'd you know if someone was
requesting that image for instance and
it would have given them the same
experience how do we have that's right
that's right it's still online storage
still relies on the same Google Network
so just as fast uh let's talk about
using storage classes together I want to
remind you again all of the storage
classes we have because we have quite a
few of them for and so multi-regional is
our storage for funded serving and
deliver its G redundant it's available
in three multi-regional locations
worldwide us you in Asia and we charge
2.6 cents per gigabyte month a simple
price per logical gigabyte month at
you're storing then going to the right
we have regional which is storage of
demise was access within a single region
I would charge two cents per gigabyte
month of storage so it's likely cheaper
and the near line and cold line is in
frequently accessed origin pole storage
and that's
photo storage costs we charge much less
for storage but we charge more for axis
and typical rule of thumb that pannier
line and state access that access once a
month or less and cold lane access once
a year or less and what's cool about all
the storage classes so they have the
same API and having that API allow us to
have
object level storage class and data
lifecycle across all of those storage
classes and you can really transition
between storage platters very smoothly
and without changing URL without
changing your API how you interact data
you can simply change in storage class
and all of your tools will keep work so
to simplify that lifecycle for you
created data life cycle across storage
classes it's a feature launched out a
year ago and we allow you to
automatically set policies and
transition data from add storage to cold
storage based on the age of the data
it's a typical example that we see is
for documents as I was telling earlier
between first 30 days that document is
accessed very frequently people
interacting editing in a document and so
you would probably be storing it in
multi-regional storage class after 30
days you can set a policy to move it
down or tear it down the near line and
then after another 90 days 180 days you
can say tear down the cold line and UCS
will take care of that cheering down and
you don't need to change anything your
API is the same your bucket name is
saying your object name is the same all
of your code will keep on working even
even if the dog even if the document
ends up and I'll call this year yeah all
the stuff people work the same it yeah
alright so some closing notes before we
switch the Q&A so I want to remind you I
have for storage classes they're tuned
for different use cases or object
storage we have the same API the same
online latency across all of them and
the trio simplifies your management of
your data and how you access them data
all of these storage classes rely on
Google Network and our peering we have
open queuing policy Google platform we
have life cycle across all of the
storage classes you can learn more about
us if you just Google Google Cloud
storage or just go to call that
counselors storage we have free tier and
free trial with DCs so please go ahead
and try it out upload your leg of
chickens and see how fast they are yeah
that's all I had so we're gonna take a
minute break and then we'll switch to
Q&A and we'll be back yeah thank you so
much thank you
you
all right thank you for listening to us
so we have quite a few questions coming
online and so we'll try to answer as
many of them as we can so we'll start
with the first one when will dcs be
available in my country and so what's
interesting about this question it's a
difference between when it's gonna be
available versus when I can store data
in GCS so this yes is really available
pretty much in all the countries in the
world where you have internet with just
few exceptions where we're not allowed
to have Google services and as we talked
about our network we have hundred points
of presence around the world and
wherever you store your data will be
delivering it in our network to the
closest point of presence and then
within public internet within that
country even if we don't have that point
of presence
oh but Google so really you can store
data anywhere in GCS in those locations
are available and access the data around
the world so it's really available or
wide so second question can I use GCS as
a content delivery network or CDN yes
you can use it because like we talked
about that edge caching it sounds quite
familiar or quite similar to CDN
sexuality but really if you want to
optimize your performance if you want
optimize your cost you can use DCSS
origin or storage for the for the
content and then use our pool clout CDN
and some of our city and partners if
you're already using CD and it's pretty
easy for you to transition move that
their internal storage into VCS while
keeping your CDN provided you're using
today and even if you don't need the CDN
even if you don't have that much public
or cashable content this yes will serve
as a basic CDN with caching that content
the edge all right third question can I
control where my data is stored
absolutely so we have about 15 regions
worldwide as we talked about the
traditional storage or using airline and
cold and in regional locations you can
select that region and store the data of
your data in one of those specific
locations and we're constantly shipping
new regions so just last week we
launched two new regions we launched the
Netherlands region and Montreal region
and we're constantly adding more and
more regions but go out from ng CS and
if you select the region will keep data
in that region and that way you can have
highest performance between compute and
storage and on top of that rolls have
three multi regional locations where we
take care of that G redundancy and
replicating data across multiple regions
within that multi regional location
all right fourth question yeah so how
long does it take to transfer and load
data using appliances this faster than
sending data over the wire so take the
latter half of that question first so
you saw that very multicolored graph
that I showed you can find it on
cloud.google.com slash transfer clients
as well basically it depends right
depends on your network situation and
how much data you have what we found is
that typically organizations have you
know a couple hundred megabit type
network connection and then they have
multiple petabytes of data so if then
you're in that sort of situation then
transfer appliance can make a lot of
sense now depending on whether or not
you have less data or perhaps a faster
connection it might make sense to upload
data over the wire instead so typically
we have two options for transfer
appliance we have a hundred terabyte
option and we have a 480 terrified
option let's take the the large one as
an example it could store up words of a
petabyte of data takes a while to load
that on dual appliance it takes a while
to ship it also to you and ship it back
to us
so it takes somewhere between a month
and two months so you gotta check out
what your network situation is and it
might make sense to use it points it
might might not all right so next
question is GCS or DCP storage GCS
faster than storage another cloud so
thinking of this question you could look
back to our key texture and all the
advances that Google has made with our
network so GCS typically would be faster
than our cloud providers for larger
objects or when you're serving that
content outside of our network because
in DCs were carrying data out for as
long as possible it's built in out of
the box you don't need to tune anything
you need turn on any acceleration you
just start using the GS will be carrying
data in our network so typically you'll
see GCS be faster than options out there
but larger objects or when you're
serving data outside of our network and
similarly with edge caching because by
default we have that caching in our
regions around the world if you make
your objects public or negative and
farther out from our data centers in
point of presence around the world in
those use cases but also typically be
faster and cloud providers because we're
serving data from the edge and you
didn't have to turn on any
CDN or integrate or doing any other
extra work this works out of the box
that fast - indeed
and then last question can you speak to
ratio of a GED versus SSD or different
services also different workloads yeah
so I don't think I can directly answer
about our ratio should but if you look
at our pricing you can see that pricing
is pretty much HDD based because Sochi
point seven cents and two point six
cents per gigabyte month so you can
assume that most of the data is stored
on hte to achieve that low low price but
as you optimize and user performance
yeah you will figure that our meta data
is probably stored to be probably stored
in memory to achieve highest level
performance for those small object
operations and then for caching as well
you can think of different layers of
cache that's like some things could be
cached on a GB SSD even memory to
achieve the highest level of performance
for hot data and frequently access data
yeah all right did you want to add
anything yes or no I think thank you
again
yeah time to say goodbye from Kirkland
Washington and we're throwing it back to
Mountain View thanks so much